so I know exactly how it feels to feel
alienated when you don't have the
language to speak about who you are when
you don't have any reference points out
there or role models in the media to
look upon to see yourself in it's
extremely difficult and that's why we do
need LGBT role models going into schools
to remind kids that they're not alone
you can be queer and have a happy life
or you can you can be whoever you want
to be and not feel like you need to
sacrifice a part of yourself and that's
what's really important so I thought
that I can never be trans and happy but
I would have to keep it a secret for the
rest of my life that my parents are
never gonna understand other than just
knowing me and a lot of it is just being
scared of the warrior from the unknown I
felt extremely alone when I was growing
up I was the only black kid in my school
and a lot of the microaggressions that
people speak about now I was
experiencing every single day and a lot
a lot of those that builds up and it can
have a real effect on you in the last
couple of weeks you've covered your
scars with artwork with tattoo yeah my
foot what I've got other self harm scars
on my legs but these ones are the first
this is the first time that I self
harmed and attempted suicide so I just
wanted to not cover them all I wanted to
like merge them with artwork that shows
me as a strong person so it's just me
basically as a superhero I'm not
entirely sure what she is why not you
should be a superhero every day right
yeah just like you know I feel really
empowered I feel beautiful I feel
intelligent I'm confident I'm I know
where I want to go in my life and this
is a point where I had none of that so
it's just showing that things really do
get better it's interesting isn't it
because we talk about the gender debate
the race debate and the word debate
conjures up images or a discussion a
civilized discussion every buddy has
information and can talk sensibly but
the issue of gender has become so toxic
why do you think that is I like to call
it the gender conversation because it
isn't a debate and I think that 40-long
trans people have been forced by the
media to try and validity our existences
or how we identify and I want to speak
about how we're all going to exist
together in society because the truth is
that trans people haven't just appeared
we've always been here
so really it's other people that need to
play catch-up not us you're invited to
advise the Labour Party on trans issues
and there was a backlash yeah this was
all because of tweets you'd sent
historically using language like gay
bashing hairy lesbian and just in light
of this toxic debate toxic discussion on
various issues I just wondered what you
think now for sure if you place it in
the context of Who I am as a person now
when I said that when I sent those
tweets which I don't condone and was
extremely stupid but I was also 22 and
identifying as a gay male so in the
context of who I was at that time it's
very different to Who I am as a person
now what you'd have said at that age if
someone had confronted you about this I
probably wouldn't probably wouldn't have
understood because I feel that as people
we grow and we grow up we we don't you
know we're not born into the world with
a perfectly aligned set of politics it's
something that we need to learn as
people and some of the most woke people
now they've had a journey to get to
where they are and when I was 21 you
know I was I attempted suicide I was not
in a good place and I definitely didn't
understand who I was as a person I
definitely didn't understand politics
like I do now I did it
show you the politics is actually more
divisive than ever what did you tell
because there was 30 people on their
LGBT Advisory Board but I was the only
one that people went after and then when
I left they went after somebody else and
then when that person left they went
after somebody else so it would have
nothing really to do with me it was
about using me as a political pawn to
try and bring down Jeremy Corbyn or
discredit Jeremy Corbyn or the Labour
Party by the conservative press three
topics had always come up mixed
bathrooms gender-neutral clothing and
gender-neutral toys were part the
bathrooms one moment because that's it
that's a quite erm shall we say hotly
contested conversation in the terms of
gender-neutral clothing and toys do you
think it's trivializing something quite
Illyria if I think when we think about
where we need to go with this
conversation it is educating from a base
level so that really does involve kids
and if a kid is if we're talking about
gender from a very early age then that's
gonna make it so much less of a problem
going down the line and I mean when we
talk about gender-neutral toilets
these things have always existed we're
just using different language there in
our homes are they well exactly they're
in our homes you go to any fancy hotel
in London and the toilets are mixed we
used to call them unisex but I think
because the language has changed and
we're just saying gender-neutral as that
have been fighting a language we're
fighting over language and it's
ridiculous these things have existed for
so long I just finally it's a long
wedding coming up this weekend mega
markle's
welcomed into the royal family as he is
being seen as a real big step for
diversity in this country do you think
it's that significant so not not really
I think on a very surface level it's
nice to see a woman of color there but
it's still a woman
in an elitist position and I think and I
don't know I feel that we're so divided
of the country anyway I think that I
don't know I don't I really don't think
that it brings any of us closer